In this part of level editing I'd like to talk about level instanced actors.
Level instanced actors allow you to take a single static mesh that's been
instanced multiple times or used multiple different places or a group of
static meshes and replace them with a new version that under the hood
replaces all of those static meshes with instanced versions of themselves
increasing speed and reusability. The image in front of us or the slider should
say in front of us shows this in action with the sandstone rocks. The image that
you're seeing is actually constructed using the four sandstone rocks and we
can do this inside of the editor by doing the following. So in our scene
here I have these rocks and if I hit shift E I'm going to go through and
actually select a few more as this is made up of quite a few different types
of rocks and things like that just to kind of show you the versatility of this.
When I've done that I have 47 actors selected so what I'm gonna do now is I'm
gonna right-click and I'm gonna go to level and we're gonna go create level
instance. Now when we do this we're gonna get the new level instanced
dialog box and what this is allowing us to do is select the pivot point for
this object and we have some options here we have center min Z which is
going to find the minimum Z value and center around that we can do it at the
exact center of all of these we can do it based off of an actor or we can do it
based off the world origin. For now I'm gonna click on center min Z and press
OK and what we're gonna get is a new save level as dialog so we're gonna
save this as MT underscore zero one and I'm gonna click save and what
you're gonna see happen here is instead of now having a group of static
meshes like I did before so let me come up here to my static mesh folder
I'm gonna collapse this you can see here now what I have is this one single
actor and if I hit ctrl B you'll see it's also been added as a level so I
can drag this in and you'll notice that I can use this multiple different
times and every time what it's gonna do is just add one of these level
instanced actors in there so again this is really useful for when I have
things that are static and I want you know just kind of like you know
maybe the player comes and runs around this maybe they don't get that
high so they can't see over the mountains and you know we make another
version to hide the cracks on the side so we can really get this to help us
kind of get started in areas or use this for areas that are off in the
distance and the players not meant to get to and we really want to have
some collection of assets to make it easier just for everything to be
manageable with how many assets things can be made out of in a modern
project now what if we want to add something a little more like I'm sure
you're thinking what do I want to add like a light or something else like an
actor or a trigger or something and this is where the packed level actors
come in now packed level actors do the same thing behind the scenes they
replace those static meshes with instanced versions of the static meshes
for performance but they also allow you to include things like lights or
different types of blueprints or triggers or things like that so let's
take a look at that inside of the editor so we're gonna come over here and
where is our little house we have a little house over here I think it's
right here so there's our little house so we're gonna click on
everything inside of the house here all right so there we go there's
everything inside of the house now what we're gonna do is before I do
that though actually I should say let's come in here and add I'm gonna hold
down L and click that's just gonna add a light right there I'll add one over
here so now that we've done that let's come back here and select everything
and then we'll also hold down the ctrl key and grab our lights as well there
we go and then we're gonna right-click level create packed level
actor again as we had with our packed level instance we can select where the
pivot point is going to be coming from for this one I'm gonna hit center
we're also gonna be asked where we want this level to be saved so we're
gonna say house underscore zero one and then also notice we're gonna get this
BP and so we're gonna click save right there as well and we're gonna
come out and so you're thinking okay well got this blueprint that was kind
of weird what's going on so we do and have two different things so first
off here's our house level blueprint so that works and if we pull that in
notice that we don't have our our lights inside of there that's okay what we
can actually do for our lights is we just grab our house here and our house
is gonna have our lights inside of it and I think our light needs to
actually be set to movable so this is actually a great segue in to editing
now one of the other cool things about this is we can edit both of these
and even break them apart into their individual components again if we want
to use these just maybe as a starting point so let's just pop over here and
look at how we could fix this so if I come here to my house zero two I could
just come here to my level and edit and if I come here to my light I
probably probably should set that to like movable and set this one to
movable and click exit yes and there we go I've changed that now the other
cool thing check this out if I was to bring this all the way over here and
let's say that for example I don't know we're gonna come in here and I can also
click the edit here to edit it I want to change this you know I don't know
change this to yellow because that's what the color needs to be when it
first starts off we'll click exit and what's gonna happen is that's actually
gonna populate and this one over here is gonna now be yellow and as I said
before we can also come to these and right click on this and break so we
can break this and you know we can't undo this action but this is now break
it broken this into its individual components so we can use this kind of
two different ways if we want we can use it for a level organizational
purposes or we can use these to help us get started maybe this is the white
box for a particular house so we know that the you know house of this size
is always going to be whoops always going to need to occupy you know this
amount of land and then as things start to progress as your project starts
to come together these eventually get replaced with their proper models so
again the editing of level instances or actors can allow you both a performance
gain as well as make it easier to share things that you've crafted out
of multiple objects and also account for utilizing things like lights
blueprints and triggers inside of your projects